Вітаю! Мене звати Любомира Мандзій.
Я виконую обов’язки Міністра освіти і
науки України.
У зв’язку з карантином ми всі працюємо
в нових реаліях разом із учителями,
учнями та їхніми батьками.
Які основні зміни відбулись в освітньому
процесі через карантин у школах?
Усе навчання відбувається дистанційно.
Інструменти дистанційного навчання —
вибір учителя.
Чим користуються педагоги в Україні?
онлайн-заняття через Zoom, Skype
організовують навчальний процес через
безкоштовні вебсервіси та платформи,
наприклад, Google Classroom, Moodle,
Microsoft Teams
використовують телеуроки проєкту
«Всеукраїнська школа онлайн»
на українських телеканалах чи
YouTube-каналі МОН
заздалегідь записують відеоуроки чи
обирають доступні матеріали із
зовнішніх освітніх ресурсів
МОН не дає чітких вказівок,кожен може
обрати ті інструменти та методи, які
для них технічно доступні.
Учні ж 4 та 9 класів звільнені від
державної підсумкової атестації.
Зовнішнє незалежне оцінювання
відбудеться за будь-яких умов.
Терміни проведення ЗНО будуть залежати
від закінчення карантину
Карантин — це не канікули. Готуйтесь!
Щодня на YouTube-каналі МОН,
телеканалах Рада та Київ транслюють
уроки з підготовки до ЗНО.
Навчальний рік у всіх школах завершиться
до 1 липня для всіх, окрім випускників.
Важливо зберегти структуру навчального року.
Я вдячна всім педагогам, які опанували
нові навички та забезпечили
безперервний освітній процес.
Пам’ятайте, на карантині гарантоване
збереження середньої заробітної плати.
Давайте підтримувати одне одного і тоді
ми точно отримаємо відмінний результат.
Усі новини на сайті, Фейсбуці та
Телеграм-каналі Міністерства
освіти і науки.